moteur tour
voilà dès que j'ai doucement tu vois la
PO
Ren si tu veux al avant la falaise et le
village c'est juste derrière attends non
non ça m'intéresse pas pour l'instant ça
m'intéresse pas du tout pour regarde
pour ce que je veux dire là ça rien à
voir le problème c'est que c'est pas
très joli autour qu on laisse tomber les
non laiss bien le faire laiss bien faire
laisse bien le faire avec les buissons
qui passent devant c'est joli voilà
c'est joli ça tu vois VO ça c'est joli
pass plein de
trucs veux les falaises aprs les fera
tout à l'heure il y a aucun problème
d'ailleurs c'est pas de l'eau ça tu vois
c'est pas l'eau ça c'est va chercher les
oignons je sais pas quoi c'est pas l'eau
ça ça ça va pas ça elle continue à
tournere mais c'est pas c'est pas ce que
je
veux
ill qui vont pas à l'école parce que
travail c'est pas pas mon
truc
bon que tu vis
FA
un la mais
bon voilà voilà la belle avec les gens
qui marchent devant je vois plus
d'ailleurs
sont la SER un petit peu
dessus
ouis plus de la gauche qu' les dunes tu
vois c'est pas grave so plus à gauche
qu' lesun en fond c'est bon c'est bon
faire comme ça c'est bon descends peu
plus bas si tu
peux bien laiss à gauche du
CRE
j'aur plus seré sur j'y va j'en fais un
j'en fais un
avec très
serré
oh merde
pardon peux faire c'est plus beau c'est
plus
joli derrière comme c'est derère écraser
FME là sur ces d là tu
vois allons
disparaître tu peux les serer plus
avir que que Fr qui va le faire qu
vraiment les quatre dans le cadre
voilà
voilà voilà encore encore encore encore
encore encore encore encore
voà un
Arre prends ton temp prend ouais mais
sinon il y a la pchère si je m'arrête
pas tu vois je gère la poussière qui est
juste à la limite de la
caméra tu peux monter la falaise
derrière tu pourrais ou pas
maintenant la
faiserière je
RAL attends on continue Contin s elle
sort elle sort elle sort sort continue
on continue on peut en faire un de face
allez
vas-y non B je sais pas j'père qu'on pas
de pour faire le petit par j'avance à
cause de la
poussièrere un
peu
Ji c'est super beau c'est super
joli piqu
ça viendre le
point c'est joli ça c'est super beau
ça on laisse sortir on pas le Cho c'est
super beau ça c'est super prend le temps
prend le temps c'est
super ok c'est bon refaire si vous
voulez ref ouais mais tu as vu y
que il pas plus tout à l'heure il y a
pas de plus de
Gresse pas les mêm
ça très joli son t-shirt bleu ouais je
pasès couleur
locale ah non c'est pas les mêmes il a
raison il a raison vas-y
arrête
arrête il a raison le
patron y en a plein il vas-y celle de
droite
doucement
je pense que ça vibre ouais P c'est pas
fac trop
serré c'est joli
J